[Music]
welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'm going to be your host
excited to be here got a great team this
evening Daniel paron welcome good to be
here and I'll tell you the reason it's
good to be here is because the word of
God is living and active and sharper
than a two-edged sword there's nothing
like having a dull sword amen good to
know ours is sharp wow amen Daniel
Marone yes what a blessing it is to be
on this program that's all kinds of
really great questions thank you guys
for sending them in appreciate you amen
John deny it's a blessing to be here and
I praise the Lord because the Bible is a
light to our feet and a light to our
path all right exactly very well put you
know we're here we receive our questions
from you and so I'm going to give you
the three Avenues of sending your
questions in uh if you want to text them
in it's 61 68 228
3975 once again 618 228
3975 perhaps you'd like to email them in
if you choose to email them it's Bible
QA at
3abn.org
and if that's the case it's
3abn _ official Once Again 3abn uncore
official this is going to be a great
program that we have here I just want us
uh uh start off with prayer and then
from there we're going to start off with
questions we got 12 questions today most
of them average around three minutes
couple of maybe four minute ones and
unless you do this you don't really
realize how much time it takes to
prepare you may have a topic this long
that we're going to put it into a pint
bottle and so uh I'm just I I respect
all three of you so much let's do have a
prayer father we come to you in the name
of Jesus and we thank you Lord for this
time we thank you Lord that that people
are interested in what does the Bible
say about this and so father as these
gentlemen has as they have prepared
answers we just ask Lord that through
the of the holy spirit that the right
words will come out of their mouths and
that we will all be blessed we love you
and we thank you in the name of Jesus
amen amen amen amen well let's have a
wonderful time guys Daniel we're going
to start with you Daniel P we got two
Daniels today so we got Daniel parin at
the end and my right Daniel morone and
then we have
John that's right amen Daniel number
your number one question why does God
have to make a new Heaven if all is
perfect there already why not just a new
Earth and this is from Tony in Canada
all right thank you Tony for this
question and let's get right into it
thinking about that text in Revelation
21 verse one that says now I saw a new
Heaven and a new Earth for the first
Heaven and the first Earth had passed
away and you can find a similar promise
also in the book of Isaiah 65:1 17 now
the answer lies in the fact that the
word heaven in the Bible can actually
refer to more than one place there's
several texts that indicate with this or
I'll read you just Deuteronomy 10:14
that says indeed Heaven and the highest
Heavens belong to the Lord your God also
the Earth uh with all that is in it so
the word Heaven can refer to the Earth's
atmosphere or the cosmos where you find
the the planets and stars or to God's
actual dwelling in heaven so God's
dwelling in heaven won't suffer any
destruction that needs to be repaired
and replaced but what about the
atmosphere of Earth let me just take you
to a few texts in the Bible like Isaiah
34:4 it says and the heavens shall be
rolled up like a scroll and their host
shall fall down Isaiah 516 for the
heavens will vanish away like smoke the
Earth will grow old like a garment or 2
Peter 3: 10-13 that says the heavens
will be dissolved being on fire and the
elements will melt with fervent heat are
you getting the picture that something
in the atmosphere of Earth is going to
be falling apart and not going to be the
the consistent nature that it has been
in the past Revelation 614 says that the
sky receded as a scroll when it is
rolled up you can picture the atmosphere
changing here or Revelation 16:17
talking about the plagues when it says
then the seventh angel poured out his
bull into the air so something happens
in the atmosphere of the Earth or
Revelation 20:9 and 10 that says and
fire came down from God out of heaven
and devoured them this is the fire that
consumes the wicked in Revelation 14: 11
says that there is smoke that arises
because of that well that smoke in the
atmosphere can't be hanging around
forever when God uh constructs A New
Earth he's got to replace the heavens as
well and so the new heaven
will also will be the atmosphere of
earth that is restored and this also
lets us know that the destruction of the
wicked here on Earth will not last
forever because the smoke will not be
rising forever there will be a new
Heavens it will be clean and pure just
as God created it back in the beginning
amen amen good answer amen
Daniel why do people celebrate December
25th as the day Christ was born and this
is from Joan
well Joan that's a fantastic question I
had to look deeply here to figure that
out or to look it up I start off with
the Britannica Encyclopedia there want
to give credit there they got this
history of December 25 it's in the 3r
century the Roman Empire celebrated The
Rebirth of the uncon unconquered son and
it was called Soul so Invictus on
December 25th and this holiday not only
marked the return of longer days after
the winter soltice which is December 21
the shortest day uh but was also
followed by a popular Roman uh Festival
saturnalia during which uh feasting and
then they exchanged gifts during that
Festival it was also the birthday of the
indoan deity Mithra a god of light and
loyalty whose cult was at the time
growing popular among the Roman solders
so the first Christian emperor in Rome
was
Constantine he converted to Christian
ity on the battlefield in 312 ad and
gave credit to the Christian God for his
victory so in 313 he proclaimed the
Edict of Milan which declared tolerance
for Christianity in his Roman Empire so
prior to that the Christians were
actually persecuted and uh so a lot of
people look at that as a political move
where he joined the empire together so
that they would have peace amongst them
and eventually Christianity became the
official religion of the Roman Empire
you've probably heard of the Holy Roman
Empire in world history the first
recorded celebration of Christmas on
December 25 was in 336 ad and that was
in the Church of
Rome and this was about six years after
Constantine had moved the capital of the
Roman Empire to the East and it became
Constantinople so this date wasn't
widely accepted December 25 in the year
in the Eastern Empire where January 6th
was the actual favored date that they
had
for another 50 years that uh
lasted but um by the way that's where
the 12 Days of Christmas came from from
between December 25 and January 6
there's 12 days that's where it
originated the days and Chris uh the
Christmas didn't actually become a major
christian Festival until the 9th century
till it wasn't until the 800s before it
became a widely accepted Festival so now
just because Jesus didn't come on
December 25 doesn't mean he didn't come
at all and and that we shouldn't
recognize his birth in other words we do
recognize December 25th isn't the time
Jesus was born and that it does have
Pagan Roots yet it is a time of year
when the world's attention turns to
religious things and the birth of Jesus
so it gives us a good opportunity as
Christians to point people to the God
who loves them and gave us Jesus again
thank you so much for that question Joe
appreciate amen
amen good answer you did some good
research right there Johnny we all know
that the feet of iron and clay and
Daniel's Visions represents the Roman
Empire as explained to Nebuchadnezzar
but does the iron appearing on the legs
of the statue also suggests that the
Roman Empire was already slightly
divided within before the 10 Kingdom
Division and this is from another Daniel
in New Zealand
very good thank you Daniel I would say
to you that um Iron is very strong as
you look at the image presented there in
Daniel you notice that there's gold
there's silver there's bronze and
there's iron all these are metals that
are valuable but the most valuable is
gold but they diminish they diminish in
value but they increase in strength so
the legs of iron indicate strength and
the way the body declares or tells us
about the iron kingdom is that it
crushes and it uh grinds to it brings to
powder it iron is very strong so in the
beginning the Roman Empire was a strong
strong Kingdom but now as you move down
towards the toes towards the feet and
the toes then you see the mixture of
iron and Clay that's when division
begins you know when you look look at a
a um a a movement or or some kind of
campaign to to do something at first the
the people are united but then as time
goes on there's infighting and then
eventually uh division so this is well
presented remember that this is talking
to us about a lot of history 168 BC to
351 ad so you can be strong and
eventually become weak and the divided
let's take a look Daniel chap 2:33 his
legs of iron his feet part of iron and
part of clay so the legs are of iron and
then eventually becomes part of iron and
part of clay so that shows weak that
shows that it begins to weaken and it
begins to be divided Daniel 24041 and on
it says in the fourth Kingdom still
speaking about Rome shall be as strong
as iron for as much as iron
as iron that breakthe shall it break in
pieces and
bruise and whereas thou sawest feet and
to part of Potter's clay and part of
iron the kingdom shall be divided now
you see Division coming in but there
shall be in it of the strength of the
iron for as much as thou sawest the iron
mixed with my clay it's been a long time
that I read King James version and as
the toes of the feet part of iron and
part of clay so the kingdom shall be
partly strong and partly broken so you
see time reveals what happens to this
great power so we see here that no not
necessarily that when you see the feet
of iron that there was already division
there was strength but then comes
Division and comes weakness so this is
uh what I see as we look at this this
particular scripture and your question
very good question I encourage you to
keep studying and
uh now you talk about the toes the 10
the 10 Kingdom we are in the very toes
now where the Bible says they shall not
cleave one to another there's going to
be an attempt and there has been attempt
throughout history and very wise very
clever way to try to bring Unity among
them by intermarriage from one nation to
another but there's always somebody that
has an agenda and there's always always
issue internal strife uh rings and
there's a long list there's a long list
of intermarriage between uh this Prince
and the princess over there in that
country and trying to bring unity in
Europe but the Bible says that they
shall not cleave one to another and the
same happens with the T toes the T toes
are separated and will remain separated
and we are in that time when the Lord
will establish very soon his kingom amen
amen great
answer Daniel paron let's go to yourself
second question can you please explain
what the meaning of Matthew 2413 is I
believe this refers to our Salvation And
this is from K in Ohio all right K thank
you for this question in Matthew chapter
24 Jesus is talking about the signs that
are leading forward to his second coming
in verse 13 says but he who endures to
the end shall be saved the message of
this really is it's not just about how
you start the race it's also about how
you finish because anybody can stand in
the church and say I do but that's not
the end of the story in the marriage do
you continue lovingly United in that
marriage Paul uses the running metaphor
in Hebrews 121 where he says let us run
with endurance or some translation say
with perseverance the race that is set
out before us he doesn't say let us just
start with energy and enthusiasm or
excitement and a burst of speed let's
run with endurance and perseverance
there's more to the Christian life than
simply accepting Jesus into our heart
because the Christian life is not just a
momentary decision to say yes to Jesus
but it's a moment by moment series of
decisions after decisions where we allow
or invite the participation of Jesus and
cooperate with him to do the work that
he wants to do in our life each of those
decisions that we Face day by day give
us the opportunity to be settled more
firmly into the life-changing truth the
complete truth and that's the complete
truth of Jesus so that ultimately when
we're settled into that truth we will
not be moved from what God would have us
to do from the character that he would
have us to express and the result then
of being settled firmly into the truth
of Jesus so he cannot be moved is that
we endure that that we uh move as the
character of Christ would move and
consider some Bible examples 32,000
Warriors started out with Gideon 32,000
started out 300 were with him at the end
many people multitudes followed Jesus
eager for his words but what does John
6: 66 say it says from that time many of
his disciples went back and walked with
him no more they started out with him
but then they said we don't like we
don't like where this is going what
about Revelation 3:5 it says he who
overcomes shall be clothed in white
garments and I will not blot out his
name from The Book of Life but I will
confess his name before my father and
before his angels blot out his name from
The Book of Life is indicating that
there are people who and you can go see
Philippians 4:3 on this at one time had
had their names written in the Book of
Life they started out well but then they
turned their back and eventually
ultimately their name did not appear in
The Book of Life the point is this God
will allow me and he will allow you to
be tested on every Earthly attachment so
that the content of our heart will be
revealed so nobody could ever say God
made a mistake God will allow us to be
tested to show either that God is
supreme because we'll lay aside every
Earthly attachment or we say my will is
supreme because we'd rather hold hold on
to those Earthly things rather than
Christ what might those things be maybe
it's a cell phone app for you or a video
series or a sports team or the approval
of your spouse or a friend or peace in
your home or the wisdom of a pastor
instead of God's word or some chocolate
chip cookies or caramel popcorn or food
at all whatever it might be God gives us
tests that allow us to say Jesus is
number one in my life and that testing
process is going to root out the
uncommitted and it's going to strengthen
the committed and it will separate the
wheat from the tears which has to happen
before Jesus returns James 1:12 says it
like this blessed is the man who endures
Temptation for when he has been approved
he will receive the Crown of Life which
the Lord has promised to those who love
him this is not a strange Doctrine in
the Bible God allows us to experience
testing to reveal our heart
Hearts great
amen
Daniel if as the psalmist declares in
Psalms
139: 14- 16 that we are fearfully and
wonderfully made why do we seek to adopt
completely new looks by changing the
natural looks which God has seen fit to
give us should true Christians be
engaging in this behavior and this is
from
Elanor well thank you Elanor for that
question great
question and as far as our natural looks
yeah natural looks well let me read a
couple of texts for our audience here
Psalm 139 says uh verse 13 says this is
from the basic Bible in English My Flesh
was made by you and my parts joined
together in my mother's body and I will
praise thee for I am fearfully wonder
and wonderfully made that was the King
James one that you mentioned and
marvelous are thy works works and my
soul knoweth right well or this my soul
is fully
conscious
and you know how can we improve upon
what God has made right that's kind of
what you're asking there so I look at
that as great Insight you know I agree
with you as far as speaking about
looking natural or trying to look
unnatural I guess I should say that we
don't want to look unnatural trying to
improve upon God's but in verse uh 13 it
says that God made us our flesh and
parts and join together in our mother's
womb so how can we improve it's like
maybe maybe I want to make my hair
purple instead of white like it is or or
maybe fill myself with tattoos you know
I said wow I want all these tattoos or
or uh piercings I want to pierce my body
um but when you asked should a true
Christian be engaging in this Behavior
you know I wouldn't want to use this as
a Criterion to determine whether someone
else it be a true Christian or not you
know when I pastored I had uh new people
coming to the church to check us out and
they didn't stay if they felt judged or
looked down upon you know like if
somebody was that way you know all with
bunch of tattoos or whatever uh so I
believe that's why Jesus said in Luke
6:37 judge not and you shall not be
judged condemn not and you shall not be
condemned and forgive and ye shall be
forgiven so I believe and you we should
look at ourselves when we look at
ourselves we want to ask God what our
motive is for what we're doing to as far
as our appearance like I had a u cousin
that was born with a cleft pallet so he
went ahead and had plastic surgery and
of course he was a little boy in this
parents did but in other words uh with
sin in the world today you know anyway
seems like we can improve some things
sometimes and make it look more
natural so 1 Corinthians 10:31 says
whether therefore you eat or drink or
whatever you do do it all to the glory
of God so whatever we're going to do in
our own appearance think of that you
know we want to glorify God and not
bring attention to ourselves or whatever
other issues we might have but when it
comes to looking at other people uh I
think we should use Matthew 71 judge not
lest you be judged thank you again for
that question amen amen good answer
Daniel Amen John I'm trying to explain
to a friend that animals don't have a
conscience and human do he doesn't
believe that he believes that everything
that's living has a soul animals are the
subject where in the Bible can I help
him with this and this is from Kimberly
in
NADA thank you Kimberly uh sometimes uh
we may have to accept that some people
will not be convinced and so let's go
ahead and take a look at what you're
saying it almost seems like your friend
is taking the word conscience and the
word so and saying they are the same
thing but let's take up let's look at
the definition for
conscience the Oxford definition is an
inner feeling or voice viewed as acting
as a guide to the righteous or wrongness
of one's Behavior an example of a
sentence would be he had a guilty
conscience about his desires uh let's
look at Websters 1828 dictionary says
internal or self- knowledge or judge
judement of right and wrong or the
faculty power or principle within us
which decides on the lawfulness or
unlawfulness of our own actions and
affections and instantly approves or
condemns them so looking at this then we
have to ask ourselves well how do we
categorize certain animals do we say
that chickens Ducks snakes worms
butterflies and cockroaches have
conscience can they uh evaluate well a
can a cure say I did wrong I shouldn't
have eaten that I mean can can they
these animals do that type of thing can
they reason that way do they know when
they have committed a sin do they have a
guilty conscience these animals that we
look at and so these are things that we
can ask ourselves to evaluate do animals
have a conscience and the reasonable
answer is no they don't have a
conscience but animals for example we
can see that certain animals seem to
have like sympathy like cats and dogs
I've seen them seem to have sympathy
when their owners seem to be sad it's
like there's an even an expression of
sympathy and they get near them and I've
seen
cats softly with their paws uh you know
uh trying to console or or comfort so
they seem to have sympathy but do they
have a conscience now as we look at the
Bible because this is Bible Q&A do we
see that the disciples or Jesus went
around preaching to I'm sorry I have to
use these type of examples rabbits
squirrels uh donkeys horses camel do
they try to lead them to repentance and
lead them to be baptized no so we can
look at this do we do we see John the
Baptist trying to baptize turkeys and
geese and cockroaches and ants and
things like that no we don't see that
since we don't see that we have to come
to the understanding that animals do not
have a con
they do not uh have uh this type of
experience that they sin and they feel
sorrow and I would tend to think that if
I see a tarantula or hungry lion they
may not they don't know me they won't
have compassion upon me uh look at uh
Genesis chapter 9 verse 1 and2 it says
so God blessed Noah and his sons and
said to them be fruitful and multiply
and fill the Earth and notice it says
and the fear of you and the dread of you
shall be on every beast of the earth and
of every bird of the air and of the and
of all that move on the earth and all
the fish of the sea they are given into
your hands so as far as a solar
conscience these these animals don't
have that time is
up but that I could just picture that as
you were explaining it so good yeah I
think that you're exactly right let me
just take a few seconds here once again
and tell you how you can contact us
perhaps something has just tweaked a
certain thought I'd like to know the
answer to that and you can submit it if
you choose by text 618 228
3975 perhaps email that's Bible
QA 3abn.org
3 Romans
13 veres 1 and 2 says we are to obey
State authorities because they don't
exist without God's permission and they
are his servants is it wrong to
peacefully protest against the
government when it is doing wrong and if
this wrong since we know Jesus did not
come for a political Uprising what would
be the right scriptural response and
this is from Jackie in
Georgia all right Jackie now first let
me say don't look to me as giving you
permission to do anything regarding
peaceful protest Search the word of God
and pray about it and God will direct
you but let me take you on a journey
through what I believe to be some
peaceful protests in the Bible in Exodus
chapter 1 there are the Hebrew midwives
the Two Chief among them shiffah and Pua
who refused to do what they were ordered
to do which was kill babies they just
peacefully protested they didn't do what
the government said had to do in Daniel
chapter 1 you have Daniel haniah mishel
and Azariah who refused to eat the
King's food now they went for a
diplomatic option they sought an
alternative but they had committed
themselves in their heart we will not
obey something that goes against the
regulations that God has given us and so
they refused now the Diplomatic uh
option did work for them in Daniel
chapter 3 haniah mishel and Azariah
refused to worship the golden image that
before them they broke the law they just
stood there they did not do what they
were ordered to do Daniel chapter 6 same
thing he was ordered to stop worshiping
the Creator he went straight ahead and
did it non-violently it was peaceful he
just went and prayed there's nothing
more peaceful I think than getting on
your knees and praying Esther invited
herself Uninvited into the king's
Chamber against the law when the lives
of God's people were at stake that's
Esther chapter 4 you could look at at
Joseph you find peaceful protest in
there against Piper's wife Jeremiah the
lives of the disciples who literally
gave their lives rather than submitting
to what was told to them to do John
Jesus disciple was exiled for the word
of God and for the testimony of Jesus
Christ we don't have specifics here but
the government governing authorities
sent him into Exile because he would not
stop obeying God when the religious
authorities commanded the disciples to
stop preaching about Jesus here's what
Peter said in Acts 5:29 Peter answered
Peter and the other disciples answered
and said we ought to obey God rather
than men in the modern era Martin Luther
King Jr summarized this in his letter
from a Birmingham Jail dated April 16
1963 and I'll share one powerful
sentence one who breaks an unjust law
must do it openly lovingly and with a
willingness to accept the penalty I
submit that an individual who breaks a
law that conscience tells him is unjust
and willingly accepts the penalty by
staying in jail to arouse the conscience
of the community over its Injustice is
in reality expressing the very highest
respect for the
law so in all of these cases of the
Bible uh there's a direct specific
conflict between God's law and man's law
and by obeying God's law they accepted
the penalty now very quickly let me get
to Romans 13 I'm not going to read it
here because often times we want to
think about what Paul what we think Paul
should have said but let's take to heart
what he actually did say Paul said that
Christians should obey governing leaders
of course if they conflict with God's
law you obey God's law but here's the
message for Christians if you're going
to get in trouble with the law it better
be for something that glorifies God's
name not for something silly like
speeding paying not paying your taxes
littering or standing on the grass if
the sign says stay off the grass if
you're going to get in trouble let it be
for something that glorifies God's name
if there's a conflict between God's law
and man's law pray pray pray pray pray
and then peacefully protest by without
reservation or hesitation obeying God's
law very well put amen amen good
Daniel your third question can you
please explain 1 Timothy 4 veres 3 and
four forbidding to marry what about Paul
who did not marry and did he send
against God and this is from
Bennington all right Bennington great
question let me just share a couple of
well what Jesus thought about marriage
and also what Paul thought about
marriage uh Matthew 1910 and 11 this
Jesus is answering what the disciples
had asked him about marriage so in verse
10 it says his disciples say unto him if
the case of the man be so with his wife
it is not good to marry but he said unto
them all men cannot receive this saying
save they to whom it is given other
words go for it if you can handle that
not get married and then in First
Corinthians this is Paul talking to the
Corinthians 7 7: 8 and9 I say therefore
to the unmarried and widows it is good
for them if they abide even as I so at
this point Paul was single don't know
for sure if he had been married or
whatever there's controversy there he
was a Pharisee and some people wonder if
he was part of the Sadducees I mean
sanhan but if they cannot contain let
them marry for it's better to marry than
to burn then verse 28 says but and if
thou marry thou Hast not sinned and if a
Virgin Mary she has not sinned
nevertheless such shall have trouble in
the flesh Now isn't that interesting if
you get married you're going to have
trouble that's what he's saying it's the
promise uh but sounds like Jesus and
Paul they're not against marriage rather
to be led by the Holy Spirit to how he
directs in your path but this first
Timothy let me read it for our viewing
audience uh 4 veres 1 to 3 now the
spirit speaketh expressly which means
distinctly or outspokenly that in the
latter times remember that latter times
some shall depart from the faith giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of devils speaking lies and hypocrisy
having their conscience seared with a
hot iron then it says forbidding to
marry and commanding to abstain from
Meats which God hath created to be
received with Thanksgiving of them that
believe and know the truth you know I
believe the scriptures is speaking of
what the Christian Church did in the
11th and 12th century it does say in the
latter times so in
101818 Benedict II formerly forbade or
uh Priestly marriages and then in 1123
the first latter in Council extended the
prohibition on Priestly marriages then
in 1139 the second latter in Council
confirmed the prohibition on Priestly
marriages declaring that holy orders
were a canonical impediment to marriage
so incidentally the Catholic Church
significantly scaled back the practice
of abstaining from meat on Fridays in
1966 when the rules were changed to only
require abstinence from meat during the
Lenton season meaning the Catholics were
no longer obliged obligated to eat only
fish on Fridays throughout the year and
if you're my age you can remember the
old calendars they used to have a little
black fish on Friday on a calendar but
anyway thank you for the question
oh I was wondering where you was going
to go with that if you're my
age how do I know Johnny how do I know
if I'm truly Walking with God and
building a relationship with him I'm
relative act I'm relatively active at
church and do what I can do to set aside
a time to study and read the Bible most
days I try to always listen to sermons
gospel songs and biblical
conversations but I can't help but feel
like I'm going through the emotions to
not actually Walking with God am I being
too hard on myself or is there something
else I need to consider to invest in a
relationship that these acts are just
not providing and this is from
Danielle thank you for the question and
the way your question is expressed helps
me to understand that your preference
your desire is to be faithful to the
Lord and you desire a close relation
relationship with him you seem to be
concerned but at the same time you're
wondering if you're being too hard on
yourself this these are not the thoughts
or questions of a person that is
interested in being in the world and
just becoming a whing or a sinner it's a
person that desires to serve the Lord
and know the Lord so I want to
congratulate you on that now I want to
go to Matthew chap 22: 37 and 38 do you
identify with these verses look what it
says there Jesus said to him you shall
love the Lord your God with all your
heart with all your soul and with all
your mind do you identify with this do
you do you see this as a a your desire
to love the Lord with all your heart and
all your soul and all your mind notice
verse 38 this is the first and great
commandment and the second is like it
you shall love your neighbor as yourself
and these two Commandments hang all the
law and the prophets do you see yourself
interested in others knowing about Jesus
do you see yourself in loveing your
neighbor I know that maybe some
neighbors or some people that you run
into may not be lovable or uh encourage
you to be kind and loving to them but
that is your if that is your desire to
be kind to those that uh are not you
then you are a person that wants to uh
serve the Lord and you are in essence
walking with the Lord now here are some
questions that you uh may want to
consider uh do you love God if you
answer that yes I do love God how do you
do you how do you feel when you sin do
you feel sorrow when you sin if you say
yes I do feel sorrow for my sin well
then you are a person that's interested
in being faithful to God and walking
close to God that's your desire to walk
close to God and not to sin how about
this question do you want to please God
because you love him if you answer these
questions with yes I would say that you
are a person that's walking or desires
to walk close to the Lord now here's
another one uh what about your thoughts
uh what are your best thoughts are your
in the sweetest the thoughts that bring
you the greatest joy are the evil
thoughts uh those that are your best
thoughts the ones that bring you the
greatest joy and the greatest happiness
or um are the evil thoughts or the good
thoughts the ones that bring you the
greatest joy if you if you say well no
the the the sweetest thoughts the best
thoughts and the greatest joy I have are
those that I think about the Lord his
promises and his promise to us that uh
he is coming to save us and give us
eternal life if those are your sweetest
thoughts then you are a person that
desires and is walking close to the Lord
and I want to encourage you to continue
following the Lord with all of your
heart amen well
done Daniel question number four can you
can you explain Luke 7: 33 and 34 four
why would people call Jesus a drunkard
did he actually drink grape juice and
this is from Anthony in Ohio thank you
Anthony and maybe you've been in a
similar situation where like Jesus it
doesn't matter what you do or say
someone's going to complain and
criticize and this is actually Jesus
who's speaking here in this text in Luke
7:33 and 34 and he's revealing what
others had to say about him so here's a
little bit of context the previous
verses to help us understand Luke 7: 29
and 30 says and when all the people
heard him even the tax collectors
Justified God having been baptized with
the baptism of John but the Pharisees
and lawyers rejected the will of God for
themselves not having been baptized by
him so Jesus speaks and his supporters
cheer and his opponents grumbled next
Jesus is going to say that it doesn't
matter what side you're on even his
supporters are going to have problems
nothing is going to satisfy this
unrighteous generation even if they are
for the time being his supporters verse
31 and 32 continues and the Lord said to
What then shall I liken the men of this
generation and what are they like they
are like children sitting in the
marketplace and calling to one another
saying we played the flute for you and
you did not dance we mourned for you to
you and you did not weep in other words
it doesn't matter what size side Jesus
is on people are going to be
dissatisfied and the evidence is coming
next when Jesus presents the varied
criticisms they're going to criticize
one way or another and here it is here's
a verse you asked about Jesus continued
for John the Baptist came neither eating
bread nor drinking wine this is pure
grape juice okay he's talking about here
and you say he has a demon the son of
man has come eating and drinking and you
say look a glutton and a wine Biber a
friend of tax collectors and
sinners the people are engaging in
something here in the world of logic
that is called an at homonym argument
where instead of dealing with the
message they attack the person and
they're going to find something to
criticize people told lies about him
then just like they do now Mark 14:56
says many people bore false witness
against them and their testimonies did
not agree the thing is Jesus was not a
drunkard and how do we know he obeyed
God's law it was his law it was the law
that he had inspired the things he wrote
in the Old Testament and the grape juice
that he drank others looked at that and
said ah I see what you're doing and they
twist things to fit their their
perverted imaginations because they
already had it out against him and were
looking for some way to accuse him and
today false Messengers are still
twisting his words and actions and
twisting the words and actions of his
faithful Representatives so so what
would give people the supposed
justification to accuse Jesus as a
drunkard well Luke records at least for
maybe five different meals where Jesus
ate with people and I don't think he ate
with them as somebody who was just sour
and grumpy he came with the joy of the
Lord and he ate with them and they said
ah look at that guy he's too happy look
at that too much joy on his face and
John Chapter 2 when Jesus turned that
water into wine that was the purest best
freshest grape Ju that ever has existed
and when people drank that that was the
perfect stuff that Jesus made so here's
the lesson people on all sides are going
to talk people are going to talk you
cannot please everybody don't try please
God instead do what's right no matter
what people say and love them while
you're doing it wow amen
good Daniel you're number four all right
is the biblical definition of marriage
only valid in the sense of a man and
woman signing papers in front of a
pastor and Witnesses in a church in
order to obtain a marriage
certificate I've often been told that it
is just a modern-day societal construct
and not necessarily a Biblical
requirement so if a man and a woman for
instance enter into cohabitation
relationship and make a commitment of
unconditional love toward each other
without signing papers
basically known as a common law marriage
is that wrong or sinful in the eyes of
God if so can you please provide
scriptural evidence and justification
for marriage being valid in the eyes of
God only under the conditions that are
certificate of marriage is legally
obtained and this is from Sheena in
Guana wow that was a mouthful question
that was a long
question well you know Sheena that's a
fantastic question because it seems like
at least in this country here were
people that seems to be the going way
just to live together and that's why
some people say that the divorce rate's
gone down because not as many getting
married so anyway that's a good question
you know God performed the first wedding
there in the Garden of Eden and he
blessed it you know says he fashioned
Eve and he woke up Adam you he made Eve
and woke up Adam he presented her to him
and he said in Genesis 2:24 therefore
shall a man leave his father and mother
and shall cleave unto his wife and they
shall be one flesh so this marriage
actually is a reflection too of uh the
godhead where they're one as far as
common law or living together without
paperwork here's a few thoughts that you
might want to consider in this first
marriage there weren't any legal
documents right what do they need them
for and in Genesis 24 we find Abraham's
servant eleazer he was commissioned to
find Isaac a wife on his way back from
this his successful 900m round trip uh
we pick up the story in Genesis 2464 and
65 and Rebecca lifted up her eyes and
said unto the servant what man is this
that walketh out to meet us and the
servant had said it is my master
therefore she took a veil and covered
herself and then in verse
67 it says that Isaac brought her into
his mother's tent and took Rebecca and
she became his wife and he loved her and
Isaac was comforted after his mother's
death isn't that a romantic story you
know so don't see any record of
paperwork or certificates there either
right okay here's Jeremiah
3:8 and this is God talking to his
people through Jeremiah the prophet and
I saw when all for all the causes
whereby backsliding Israel committed
adultery I put her away and given I had
G put her away and given her a bill of
divorce now that I don't know how to
pronounce this very good but this is the
strongest concordance for that word bill
of divorce it says uh
it's the Hebrew word I'm going to try to
say it safer cifra and it was translated
bill which actually means a writing the
art of a document by implication a book
a bill book evidence anyway it was
something legal there so if there's
something legal for a divorce then you
know there had to be something legal for
a wedding also yet her treacherous
sister Judah feared not but went and
played the Harlot also then in Matthew
19:7 uh they're asking why did Moses
then command to give a writing of
divorcement so again writing of
divorcement so then there had to be a
writing of uh marriage to put her away
verse eight goes on to say Moses and
this is really key because of the
hardness of your hearts suffered or
permitted you to put away your wives but
from the beginning it was not so so it
sounds like sometime after men's Hearts
became hardened that certificates or
contracts are something written came
into existence and it was for the
woman's protection you know in times
past wives were considered to be the
husband's property so you asked about
scriptural evidence if it was a sin it's
a good question the scriptures that come
to mind are Malachi 2:14 which says yet
ye say wherefore because the Lord hath
been witness between thee and thy wife
of thy youth against whom you whom thou
Hast dealt treacherously that means
sinfully yet she is thy companion or
friend we would say and the wife of thy
Covenant and again this Covenant it it
means a compact A Confederacy a league a
treaty or an alliance and today we would
say it's a legal commitment in the terms
of marriage it refers to a formal
marriage contract then in James
4:17 this other one says to him that
knoweth to do good and doeth it not to
him it is sin thank you again for the
question
amen wow good Johnny your last question
in Matthew 12
1-8 Jesus seemed to use a bad example to
justify why the disciples picked heads
of grain and ate it on the Sabbath he
says that David did what was unlawful to
do it almost sounds like he agrees with
the Pharisees what's he trying to say
and this is from Jonathan and
Nevada thank you Jonathan upon close
examination you will notice that is not
a bad example it's a great example
actually let's go ahead and read Matthew
12: 1 through eight at that time Jesus
went through the grain fields on the
Sabbath and his disciples were hungry
underlining hungry and began to plug
heads of grain and to eat and when the
Pharisees saw it they said to him look
your disciples are doing what is not
lawful to do on this
sabbath and verse three but he said to
them have you not read what David did
when he was hungry underlying hungry he
and those who were with him how he
entered the house of God and ate the
showbread which was not lawful for him
to eat nor for those who were with him
but only for the priests or have you not
read in the law that on the Sabbath the
priests in the temple profane the
Sabbath and are blameless yet I say to
you that in this place there is one
greater than the temple but if you had
known what this means I desire mercy and
not sacrifice you would not have
condemned the Guiltless for the son of
man is Lord even of the Sabbath so as we
look at this passage we see here several
things that help us to understand Jesus
says that the the uh the priest do
things in the temple that appear not to
be um lawful but they are blameless in
the same manner Jesus uh said say that
what the disciples were doing he says
you would not have condemn condemned the
Guiltless Jesus is declaring the
disciples Guiltless blameless
innocent and when Jesus says for the son
of man is even lord of the Sabbath he is
saying I have I have such Authority and
I am the lord of the Sabbath if they
were breaking the Sabbath I would tell
you I would be I would I would declare
them guilty because he is the lord of
the Sabbath so he is saying they are
Guiltless so um here is what we have the
situation with David is that this was
not oh uh I guess we're hungry do you
want where do you want to eat well let's
go to the temple and get some showbread
there no this was that there was no food
they were in a situation where they were
being hunted they were hungry this was
an urgent situation so when you go to
1st Samuel chapter 21 let's go ahead and
read verse 3 4 and 5 now there was under
now therefore what is under thy hand
give me five loaves of bread in my hand
or what is present there was an urgent
need they were hungry and they were very
exhausted and the priest answered David
and said there is no common bread under
my hand but there is hollowed bread if
the young men have kept themselves at
least from women and David answered the
priest and said to unto him of a truth
women have been kept from us about these
three days since I came out and the
vessels of the young men are holy and
the bread is in a manner of common ye
though it were Sanctified this day in
the vessel so uh the priest told him if
you are under these conditions he
appeared to think it was okay so he
allowed them otherwise he would say no
no no you cannot eat this bread so here
among those that Jesus was talking to
they knew they knew that David was
considered blameless for what they did
so Jesus presented this example to them
to let them know they are blameless so
are my disciples amen we're going to
take a short break be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at by Bible qa3
[Music]
abn.com back guys do we have any final
thoughts or additional comments we got
back about minute and a half yeah I'd
love to leave you with the best peaceful
protest in all the Bible see pilate uh
gave permission for his seal to be used
to seal the stone over Jesus tomb and
guess tomb guess what happened in
Matthew 28:2 an angel of the Lord came
down and broke the seal rolled away the
stone and Jesus came out from the tomb
amen amen
amen well that one about uh not judging
you know we've used that thing where
well we don't want to be judges but we
can be fruit inspectors right you know
you shall know them by their fruit the
Bible says so any I'll just throw that
out there knowing people by their fruit
maybe what they're expressing on the
outside do they have love joy do they
have peace and longsuffering and all of
those things so anyway amen want to
leave you with that amen amen uh
Danielle you say is there something else
I need to consider to invest in a
relationship that these acts just are
not providing I would encourage you you
didn't really mention prayer much and
I'm sure you do pray but I want to
encourage you to consider having more
time in prayer you know I read in my
readings I I remember one saying prayer
is the better half of studying
so uh study the life of Jesus Christ and
dedicate time to pray and really talk to
the Lord from your heart and I believe
you will be blessed amen amen first of
all I just want to thank y'all I want to
thank each one of you for watching uh
sharing this time with us I want to read
a scripture for to you right quick found
in John 14:27 that means a lot peace I
leave with you my peace I give to you
not as the world gives do I give to you
and let your heart not be troubled
neither Let It Be Afraid you know Jesus
loves you with all his heart and I know
that we love you too we appreciate you
spending the time with us and just hope
that uh that your days are great enjoy
God bless
[Music]